good afternoon and thank you for giving
this opportunity to talk to all of you I
know that you've already had a long day
and it's very hot but we'll try to deal
with the topic that hopefully is a
little bit of interesting and exciting
and I'm sure you may have a lot of
questions that hopefully I can answer
for you the topic that I'm going to be
discussing with you today is a EU both
private and public responses to the
financial crisis and as we all know this
is not only a financial crisis but it's
an ongoing crisis in which we seem to be
lurching from drama to drama almost on a
daily basis and as you also know France
is of course a very major player for
good or for bad and just in the last
three days we have had the recurrence of
the french belgium bank dexia which
seems to be throwing everything one more
time into turmoil but also which may be
perhaps a flashpoint to bring about
perhaps some more radical and immediate
changes and reforms what I would like to
do is to look at a variety of responses
and I want to start with the political
responses then look at more of some of
the technical economic responses and
then what I call the impact and in a
sense of cross correlation of economic
and culture economic cultural responses
when we talk about political responses
to a crisis between Europe and the
United States I think we immediately
have to think about the perceptions and
misperceptions of the role of government
and this is a very very important issue
because the idea of governments
intervening taking control and in a
sense taking over major private
institutions in times of crisis is
something which is fundamentally
acceptable in the European historical
psychic it is something which is
fundamentally unacceptable and shocking
in the United States and I just want
very quickly to revert to the start of
this whole mess and remember this is
literally exactly three years ago a
month ago September 15 2008 Lehman fails
after last minute desperate attempts to
find what we called a white knight which
was actually supposed to be the Barclays
Bank in London and we immediately have
global repercussions the Dow drops 900
points we have a sensation of total
panic across the American economic
landscape as within literally two weeks
we see not only Lehman we see AIG one of
the world's largest insurance company
that needs a bridge loan to even survive
we have Freddie mean Freddie and Fannie
in other words the two largest mortgage
back institutions in the United States
which interestingly enough unknown to
most of the American public had actually
been privatized about 20 years before
and suddenly had to be realized we not
only have Lehman that basically
collapses we also have the cobia bank we
have Merrill we have a whole series of
crisis upon crisis in enormous rapidity
and very deeply and scouts at the very
foundations of the American economic
system what is the response in Europe
you may remember that between September
and december two thousand eight despite
the collapse of iceland despite the fear
of imminent collapse of UK banks overall
the european response interestingly
enough is clarity speed and coordination
americans are astonished and and you
know the the saying that and i'm sure
you know this of course in France and in
the united states that this was one of
the absolute first times in history that
france decided to put practice before
theory
what actually happens every day um and
this was very important because this
immediately gave a sense that all of the
EU governments we're going to undertake
in sync a number of the following steps
they all immediately increased insurance
deposit deposit insurance for the banks
across the board which had occurred in
the United States from a hundred
thousand two hundred fifty thousand
considering that all bank regimes across
Europe still functioned on national
lines and that at that time the concept
of a financial plan to harmonize the
European financial and banking industry
was still a work in progress and had
been a work in progress since 1994 yet
despite all of that the banks and the
government's work to do the following so
you have the increase in deposit
insurance you have if and when necessary
either nationalization or as in the UK
so called partial nationalization of the
largest banks of Barclays of Lloyds of
hvo you also have what is even more
important imposed capital injections and
what that meant was that all major banks
around Europe were basically told by
their governments you will accept large
recapitalisation and capital injections
whether you like it or not and it was
quite fascinating from a cultural
perspective the responses the initial
response from the BNP was you know I
think we can take care of ourselves the
initial response from Deutsche Bank was
even more striking in which ockerman the
CEO of Deutsche said we will certainly
not accept government money that would
be shameful despite all of that it was
going to happen but if the government's
the banks and the EU structures worked
in sync and immediately stabilize the
system and gave out the message to the
markets that European banks were fine
there was an interesting flip side on
perception what was the response to this
crisis in Europe
who was to blame America who was
immediately to blame cowboy capitalism
and you know the phrase cowboy
capitalism is rather charming because it
was originally coined by expansion in
1983 in which they came out with that
and it of course was at the heart of the
response of the 1987 financial crash on
Wall Street where the European press led
by the French press immediately accused
Americans of this sort of Wild West
capitalism and the idea was and I just
want to read to you a couple of of just
quotes between the end of 2008 late fall
and beginning of 2009 remember that in
the United States not only that the
government have to right away intervene
and take control and just the technical
term of the processes under which it
took control was called tarp and tarp
stands for troubled asset relief program
the tarp went along with even a more
technical mechanism which was called
tell which was term asset backed
securities loan facility which basically
meant that the government was going to
take control and responsibility for the
liabilities of every one of these banks
as things got worse or were they to get
worse and was going to pour in an
enormous amount of money into the
financial system now the next step to
this was finding out that the damage and
the exposure of US banks was even far
deeper the same sort of thing we're now
going through with EU banks but in 2008
it was US banks the exposure was far
deeper and therefore the risk for even
greater what that meant was that in
February of 2009 end of January February
2009 the US government had to come in
and actually take a thirty-six percent
share of citicorp at Citigroup so you
have here this huge global American
institution which is literally the
symbol of American capitalism run amok
around the world and all of a sudden you
have the government
coming in and having basically to
nationalise partial naturalization
nothing terribly dramatic from European
perspective there's only thirty-six
percent but what are some of the
responses and it's rather interesting
first of all we see economic and
political discourse which tended to use
and to misuse all forms of terminology
whether you were talking about
naturalization capitalism socialism
depression everything became fraught
with an enormous amount of political and
emotional context in February 2009
februari 16 2000 ein the cover of
Newsweek which is a prominent American
publication heralded the following this
is on the cover I quote we are all
socialists now the perils and promise of
a new era of big government and a
firestorm broke out in American politics
particularly among the disgruntled
conservative faction of the Republican
Party where the same day is the
Citigroup announcement Rush Limbaugh the
most popular conservative radio show
host in America said the following I
quote we cringe to watch capitalism and
subject all drama has broken loose just
one last vacation there was a cartoon
that appeared in The Boston Globe at
that time showing Chairman Bernanke and
two of the other governors of the
Federal Reserve sitting around a table
and they're saying the following
nationalization sounds to socialist to
Swedish suppose we call it something
more all-american looking happy they
announce we declare the Patriot ization
of the banks they stand up Bernanke
waving a little flag pledging allegiance
and say operation and during finance so
why is this important because this gives
you a sense of how deeply this went in
to not only the American political
discourse but also hit American popular
culture how profoundly there was this
total sense of confusion and in a way of
betrayal and a sense of what has
suddenly happened to the system which is
so profoundly part of American financial
mythology now the reality is that on
both sides of the Atlantic for a decade
and we really have to understand
sometimes a historical concept and the
context of these perceptions because
let's remember them since 1999 to 2008
on both sides of the Atlantic there was
the general sense that the American
system had been deemed infallible you
would only keep on merging banks would
keep on getting bigger property prices
would keep on expanding opportunities
would keep on booming it was only way to
go was up in 2007 there was an article
in The New York Times called the second
guilded age and Sandy vile who at that
time was no longer but had been the CEO
of Citigroup said the following I quote
the whole world is moving to the
American model of free enterprise and
capital markets can't go wrong now what
happened in the ensuing year bringing us
to where we are there began to be a
sentiment both in the United States and
in Europe that overall despite the
enormous shock and impact of what had
happened with Lehman and American banks
that there was after all light at the
end of the tunnel we were beginning to
see mild but still slowly steady
recovery of the economies or if not
recovery certainly stabilization there
was the sense that Europe had come out
of this fairly unscathed
i mean i can tell you myself from the
courses I teach from all the lectures I
give in two thousand end of 2009
beginning of 2010 there really was sort
of the sense that you know Europe seems
to be fine European Bank certainly be in
peace entendi hsbc Joyce really there
okay so now let's move on and let's see
how we can start some sort of more
co-ordinated regulatory reform to
presuming Lee guarantee this doesn't
happen again I mean this seemed to be
the overall momentum in March 2010 when
the Greek crisis breaks out the initial
response is fairly muted the initial
idea in the financial press and academia
in the markets there's this great
interest in this there's no question and
there's a little bit of confusion
because the confusion largely is why is
this actually such a big problem what is
this exactly and i can tell you i was
gonna so many times on bloomberg and
elsewhere and being asked well you know
what does that mean you know what is and
the initial response was look this is a
problem but in reality greece is only
two point seven percent of the broader
EU gdp if this is in other words the
same thing as if we had a major crisis
in Connecticut hi so this is not
something that is that romantic
presumably it's containable the thing
that was beginning to be a little bit
disturbing was that it appeared that the
Europeans themselves were dragging out
how to resolve this problem the other
thing that began to trickle into market
perception was that maybe we were not
getting all the information
again because particularly in the United
States and I'm going to talk about this
in a few minutes there is very very
little historical memory in fact there
is very severe historical amnesia that
historical amnesia usually seems to go
roughly anything that happened three
months ago so what that meant was very
very few people even in the educated
financial media and press understood a
couple of things one what was really the
difference between eurozone and non
eurozone countries what was the
overarching historical and economic
framework of the European Union and the
basis of european monetary unification
the other issue was Greeks itself
everyone had forgotten and I'm afraid on
both sides of the Atlantic that in 1999
Greece did not come into the eurozone
because everyone knew they weren't ready
so when degrees actually come in in 2001
because politically it made sense and
politically in relation with Turkey in
relation with the overall complex
situation and interrelationships of
politics and economics in Europe it made
sense the Greeks fudge the numbers from
day one but the world was doing well the
economy was booming let's move on this
was not understood and yet there was
beginning to be a sentiment of i would
say ill ease finally in May of 2010 when
the first European the financial
stabilization facilities were finally
set out there began to be a sense okay
they have now this huge fund they seem
to be working much more closely in sync
between the European Central Bank the EU
Commission the IMF and the national
Treasuries and here i also want to
mention an interesting aspect mmm we
have to remember that a particularly
economic information as its conveyed in
global media becomes very often
looted it has to be simplified it has to
be presented in ways that are clear so
the people who actually represent their
countries and represent institutions are
enormously important to this kind of
discourse the huge advantages that
Europe had was having as French Minister
of Finance Christina gout having
dominique strauss-kahn head of the IMF
tanisha as head of the European Central
Bank people who had global recognition
and who fundamentally a great deal of
respect in the United States you also
had on the German side which now go with
Skywalker you had people who wit map her
wits aqua Z people with whom America was
comfortable so this was certainly a
major issue in feeling they can get it
together and they will move forward and
the issue of Christine Lagarde is
particularly significant because we have
to remember that for the United States
not only was Madame de Gavin Tarly
Anglophone but profoundly profoundly
literate and knowledgeable of American
corporate culture she was the perfect
innocence translator to America of what
Europe was doing and and I have to be
very frank with you right now you have a
brand new finance minister in France
France wabo Anna no one really knows him
he's a he's a unknown and I'm not saying
he may not be just fine but it's very
different right now at a time of crisis
to have an unknown good so these were
issues which seem to make people feel
okay but as I said the crisis was still
seeing a debt crisis okay that's fine a
debt crisis while the banks and let's
remember was still claiming solvency all
of the European banks were saying yes of
course we have some exposure absolutely
no real disclosure was coming out and
you all know why because French
corporate history it is deeply deeply
ensconced and institutional his
in France thank you have levels of
secrecy enormous levels of secrecy the
fundamental concept of so-called
transparency clarity disclosure
accountability terms that americans love
whether they observe them or not are
barely given lip service in France so
okay the issue of French banks was
essential because of the enormous
presence of French banks also in the
United States the other issue is German
banks it appeared across the board that
goyte and commerce and Dresner having
gone through the merger in 2007 were
absolutely clean not a problem where
were their problems in germany in the
Landis Mountain where the subsidies out
of the EU had stopped by 2005 there
there were problems but that was a local
issue that was not necessarily going to
impact on US markets it looked in Italy
like any creditor was still doing fine
overall and as you may remember even as
of a year ago Berlusconi looked somewhat
more credible than he does in our days
all right so it was a little bit of a
sense maybe it's okay and the UK it was
there were major problems but after
partial or full nationalization of royal
bank of scotland Barclays and Lloyds it
appears that these banks had against
stabilized and were moving forward
without major problems so these are
issues that are important to understand
excuse me because even that's right now
I'm sorry Barclays the they was that
split in Barclays and the split in
Barclays was between Barclay asset
management where there was the sense
that they were doing okay in fact they
actually were had a excellent results
and part of Barclays which had to be
taken under the wing of the race
government so the the thing was though
that again whatever whatever situation
these banks were in the idea was still
this is a local problem they seem to be
doing dealing with it government seemed
to be have it under control we are not
seeing any more dire effects hitting
America
banks assume and the other assumption
was that this is a bank crisis we have
now moved into a debt crisis and
therefore we have now moved into an
issue where how are the credit agencies
dealing with sovereign debt issues how
are other entities dealing with
something that is no longer financial
crisis this was of course the enormous
mistake and the enormous lack of
information because once it became clear
that this was not a question of a
separate debt banking financial crisis
but rather what we came to learn misuse
me within basically the last six months
as more and more information started to
pour out and as it became clear that the
fragility of these institutions was far
deeper because of far far greater
exposure to actually Greece then what
happened was in the United States a term
was quite was coined which is a horrific
term in my view the pigs and what is the
pic sample p i I GS Portugal Italy
Ireland Greece Spain okay now it's a
terrible term and in my opinion it's a
very stupid term because in reality
every one of these countries is not
identical to every other one of these
countries the reality is that an ireland
there was a banking crisis and therefore
the sense of how Ireland chose to
resolve its particular problem is
totally different than what would would
not be applicable to Portugal or degrees
the situation in Portugal was dire but
interestingly enough for other reasons
as like the situation in Spain so there
was no but the perception began to be
wait a minute and this was in the
financial channels this was in the
financial press you began to have the
perception you know what not only do
they have grease look at this they have
this whole bun
and remember that term pigs and carried
all of the negative connotations these
big lumbering useless entities that seem
to be feeding at the trowel of
government subsidies and basically
government funding it was a
misperception but very easily began to
feed into market fear the issue also had
to do with something more fundamental in
the understanding of how Europe worked
the United States looked at the
situation in Europe and said two things
why can't they get their act together
economically why can't they decide
whether they're going to drop these
weaker members just off the map what is
the problem there was absolutely no
debate and absolutely no understanding
that fundamentally the European Union of
the European monetary union from the
very start was not an economic framework
it was a political framework it was a
political engine it was political will
it was historical will that moved
forward every single economic strategy
from 1957 on the this is an element that
really did not come through in the
perception in the United States the
other issues that began to create panic
and I'll talk about this in a moment
were the visuals and the semantics the
semantics this issue of the so-called
pigs and how was interpreted the visuals
had to do with endless pictures of riots
and grease and endless pictures of riots
literally moving everywhere and of
course through the summer in London
which created literally a panic in the
US but what was wrong with the visuals
that Americans looked at at Greece first
of all we have to understand that the
idea of immediate demonstrations by
specific factions usually union and
left-wing factions which is part of your
pian
history is not part of American
political history and has not been part
of American political history for
decades and decades so this is number
one the other issue was you were looking
at these pictures of the Greeks writing
well the interpretation and I have heard
this across the board people would say
well wait a minute you have well-dressed
presuming Lee well fed people in very
nice sunglasses who seem to be walking
around or sitting in cafes smoking and
seem terribly upset about something or
another but it looks like a very nice
sunny day what exactly is their problem
this again may be superficial it may be
false but it feeds into a sense of okay
so you have entire countries in the
European Union we're presuming Lee
people retire at 55 where and in fact
it's true in Greece twenty-seven percent
of the Greek economy is the public
sector where in fact people have very
lovely generous pensions and because
Greece is a delightful lovely country
they do sit in cafes and they do have a
drink and they do smoke and they do seem
to enjoy themselves remember we are
still in the United States and a very
very complex dual structure yes cowboy
capitalism and also profound Calvinist
Puritanism on work ethic so you can do
anything you want and make a massive
amount of money but you work very hard
and you're still highly regulated and
that is totally different than Europe
and again there was the sense then why
are we beginning to feel nervous why is
there beginning to be a massive impact
in the sense of instability and the
banks the structures these governments
at large what is going on here so huge
amount of misunderstanding the other
thing that made the situation worse is
we are now in the u.s. in one of these
endless 18-month electoral cycles as you
know
of course in France your election
campaigns and you certainly have one now
coming up in June but it's still a
roughly six weeks month and a half long
two month-long campaign in the United
States because of money because of the
funding because of the enormous
complexities of the primaries because of
a number of other issues in this huge
country with entirely different
geopolitical and geo economic zones
electoral campaigns and presidential
campaigns can literally last 18 months
why is this a problem this is a major
problem because in a lot of ways the
White House and Obama have paid very
little attention to Europe to begin with
and now have very little interest in
what's going on there so there is very
little sense of a real direct contact
and fostering of interest and awareness
of what is Europe what is the situation
what is happening the other issue that's
very complicated and when I mentioned
about semantics the definition of
liberalism the definition of liberal
economic policy the definition of
socialism the definition of
nationalization of privatization is in
reality and they may be exactly the same
terms right knee behind Lester ladies as
young people tease us young exactly the
same terms and they have extremely
difficult at different meanings right
they do not fundamentally apply to the
same concept of that integral
relationship between the government and
the private sector between the role of
responsibility between the state and
civil society and this is another issue
the issue of basically Obama being
detached from Europe does have
repercussions because there is again
sometimes the sense Europe is now being
a problem we don't want Europe to be a
problem this is a white house that is
obsessed
right now and in many ways correctly so
with two wars with China with the
economy all of a sudden you have
chemisty guys there who has to worry
about Europe Europe is supposed to be a
safe sound stable a lie occasionally
Europe is an extremely annoying ally as
the Americans found out during the Iraqi
war from 2003 to 2006 and you may
remember then the responses the shock
that suddenly Europe turned against the
US so that you had some idiot
congressman in Washington who suddenly
said we no longer have french fries and
French toast we have freedom fries and
freedom toast i we you know are going to
basically get rid of delightful and
delicious French wine and we will put
horrific tariffs on foie gras and of a
cloth and I guess we'll all feel better
but the reality was that still there was
the sense on a profound level in a
highly volatile and very a fragile
global economic environment Europe
should not be a cause of concern and all
of a sudden it is this is a problem the
other issue that also triggered panic in
the markets in the late spring middle of
May in 2011 as the crisis in Greece was
getting worse as exposure of the banks
was getting greater as it was clear that
the IMF the ECB and the EU would have to
work more in sync and that was the
Dominique strauss-kahn scandal let's
forget about the personal issues the
issue and I was interviewed constantly
about it the issue to me that was the
most troubling was this was the last
time in this was the worst possible time
to have a more volatility in the basic
institutions it meant all of a sudden
Dominique strauss-kahn had to abdicate
his position at the IMF they had to go
out and find someone new luckily and
very wisely madam logout came in and it
was right away a sense okay someone
isn't
but this all played in and it played
into the idea wait a minute who is in
charge in Europe and let's remember
another thing this goes all the way back
to the famous kissinger phrase from 1973
you know if i call europe who answers
hey who's in charge the differences and
in a sense of facilitation of the
political process and the lisbon treaty
has had no impact at all in the
understanding the union united states i
mean i don't know how many people in
europe know what it's actually done but
certainly not in the US hi so the fact
in europe unfortunately and I always
thought this was a very big mistake I
have to tell you this to have named a
president an EU president and a
so-called minister of equivalent
Minister of Foreign Affairs I'm sure the
mr. Rumpy and madam Ashton are perfectly
fine individuals but they are unknown
quantities they do not present to the
world a sense of individuals where
people can say aha this is who we deal
with so again it would fall back to in
fact yes to tree share to in fact
Sarkozy to merkel to basically the sense
of okay are these people going to be
able to take charge and remember this is
confusing because in the united states
you say we have the white house we then
at the central bank the Federal Reserve
and you have Treasury so you're dealing
with a secretary of the Treasury there
is no EU Treasury you are dealing with
the head of the central bank or on the
government level you are dealing with
the white house think about it in Europe
if you look at the financial press if
you look at all of the headlines there
are times when we're told machan and
Sarkozy made a decision there are times
when we're told we ship made a decision
there are times when we're told various
ministers and national governments made
as if it is confusing and that adds in
some ways now let me very quickly move
on to some specific econ
responses we have been suffering in the
last roughly six month by what I call
market bipolarity and what I mean by
that is we literally have gotten to a
point and you all know this where the
market goes up 500 points it goes down
300 points it goes up to 250 points it
goes down 500 points and often for
absolutely no good reason some of it has
to do with hyperbolic and semi
hysterical press and a lot has to do
with 24 7 News and with 24 7 financial
transactions remember today markets
function instantaneously markets often
function on a very highly computerized
transactions the speed the absolute
necessity to respond and react is so
enormous in markets of such vast amounts
of electronic money flowing through on a
global scale is that this in a sense
influences these extremely bizarre and
sharp ups and downs and at the end of
the day this is troubling because if the
market goes up 500 points because it
looks like the Europeans are having a
good day and agree on something and the
market goes down 300 points because it
looks like Greece suddenly isn't happy
and the market goes up 450 points
because suddenly Madame Mackler made it
clear that the German parliament is a
law is moving along with her and then
the market completely flips and goes
hysterical because it appears that the
UK is nervous about the whole thing so
who do we trust and this is a very very
important issue on both sides of the
Atlantic who do we trust has there been
a very profound intrinsic loss of
confidence in the very anchors in the
institutions in the pillars same problem
with the credit rating agencies hey I
mean this is another issue this is both
in Europe what we are now discovering is
that literally every one of the major
banks in Europe has enormously more
exposure to Greek debt to Portuguese
that the Italian death then perceived
before
we are also discovering that the numbers
that Greece provided for the EU for
literally 10 years were so one hundred
percent false that they don't even have
any bear into reality we are also
basically discovering that these same
credit rating agencies that now are
downgrading not only countries remember
all of Italy's been downgraded the US
was downgraded but the major banks have
been downgraded BNP correctly called
right any creditor have been downgraded
so that's very nice but then we go back
a year ago and we said we'll wait a
minute how come in 2009 and 2010 the
credit agencies thought all these banks
were marvelous they all have triple-a
rating or these countries did how come
the stress tests in july two thousand
ten ninety banks only seven failed you
all know that the last stress test in
july two thousand eleven dexia had some
of the best scores so what does this
mean and this is a very deeply troubling
time now i just want to remind you of
something between the united states and
europe since 1992 there has been very
strong euro skepticism in the united
states on the concept of european
monetary notification what is
interesting is that from 1992 to 1999
top american economist especially martin
feldstein at Harvard Rudy Dorn Bush
basically have declared and he's still
declaring the whole thing's a disaster
and waiting on the other side of the
coin you had Robin Mandel here at
Columbia who in 1998 and I hope we're
able to provide you with this article
March 24 25 1998 in the Wall Street
Journal Robert Mundell wrote a two-part
article which gave the first official
benediction to creating a European
monetary union and the euro which is
quite fascinating and very important but
they have always been these two schools
of thought today Larry Summers an
article on the FD a few weeks ago
picking up some of the major points from
no doubt and declaring basically a very
important point that the fundamental
strength of Europe and the euro is that
politicians will always desire to
preserve it while markets will always
have the ability to bet against it does
this dichotomy is there and it's deep
now today if we have larry summers
saying there's somehow going to have to
fight and get it together and i have to
tell you from my own dealing with larry
summers when i was in washington he
always had a positive attitude and i'll
talk about that in for one second on the
other side you have nouriel roubini that
you have george soros who keep on saying
for god sakes just ditch all these
countries off and let's move on so this
is also ensconced in the American
mindset how do we look at these issues
and I have to tell you I was in washing
him the Clinton administration I was an
adviser and finance policy because I'm
French and I was dealing with Europe and
I wrote up and started what's called a
multi-agency initiative on euro dollar
competitiveness and there were three
responses and this was in the nineteen
ninety six to nineteen ninety-eight
period one of them was pleased the
Europeans will never get it together
look what happened to them in the
currency crisis of 92 93 what happened
the second one was you know if it does
happen you can't create a currency
overnight this will absolutely not even
be a problem the dollar total hegemony
of the dollar number three if and when
it happens we'll deal with it then those
were the three responses some of this is
still fundamentally in place okay now
why is some of this so hard at times to
understand part of this has to do with
perception of time and perception of
history in political phenomenon just
September 30th in the New York Times it
was a very good article and I quote in
European crisis little hope for a quick
fix
Americans fundamentally want solutions
they want them quickly and they want
them efficiently Europeans want
resolutions it's a very big difference
there is very little understanding as I
mentioned of the complex
interrelationship between politics and
economics at the heart of the EU there
is also a profound lack of knowledge
across the United States in lemme Ithaca
phoned in the heartland of America of
what in the world is the euro and what
is the eve that's why we can have
headlines is the u.s. becoming Greece
are we all now becoming like the Greeks
which makes no sense whatsoever if you
went across the United States and you
talk to people about the euro they would
answer yeah that's really great you know
now tourism is so much easier whenever
we go to different countries we only
need one currency that's the extent of
the knowledge hey there is very little
discourse into the fundamental debates
that are taking place in Europe and
there is also often not a complete
understanding that even if your
appearance don't like the United States
even if you want to criticize it you
still want in Europe a strong sound US
economy there is an enormous amount of
interest in Europe for the united states
in this country particularly in times of
elections there is relatively very
little interest of what happens abroad
and what happens in Europe as I said you
know going back to after nine eleven
Europe is a sound stable a lie there was
the shock of the response in Iraq but
Europe was mixed remember some countries
were forced somewhere against but there
was still the sense you know what
everything else that's going on they
still seem to be doing fine they are not
a problem I this is very very important
so the idea of benign neglect seems to
be fine I want to open it up now to
questions but we are right now at
where we still need to sense that the US
and Europe are safe havens in this
economy and I just want to mention one
interesting criteria to despite all of
the problems that have been going on for
the last 10 years the ratio of reserves
in dollar and euro in global central
banks has literally not moved central
banks across the globe still holds
sixty-five percent of their reserves in
dollar roughly thirty percent in euro
and the other five percent in Swiss
franc canadian dollar austrian and
sterling so there is still very much
despite all that we hear about all these
new markets and everything else there is
still the sense that somehow or another
these countries have to continue to
function very much in sync that Europe
not only fundamentally and I believe it
will has to now pick itself up and find
a solution even at enormous cost an
enormous sacrifice the United States the
same but one way or another there has to
be some steps forward to somewhat re
stabilizing the global environment and I
want to end here and I'm